♪ ♪
>> Jesse: WHERE IS TONY DANCER
WHEN YOU NEED HIM?
ALYSSA MILANO PROTESTING AT THE
GEORGIA CAPITAL AGAINST THE
STATE'S NEW ABORTION BILL.
THE LEGISLATION FACING LIBERAL
BACKLASH FOR BANNING ABORTIONS
AFTER A FETAL HEARTBEAT IS
DETECTED WHICH USUALLY HAPPENS
AT ABOUT SIX WEEKS.
MILANO, LEADING A GROUP OF OVER
100 CELEBRITY'S, THREATENS TO
BOYCOTT FILMING IN THE STATE
WHICH COULD COST GEORGIA
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
ON TUESDAY, MILANO DELIVERED A
LETTER SIGNED BY HER FELLOW
CELEBS TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND SHE WAS CONFRONTED BY STATE
REPUBLICAN LEGISLATOR.
>> I WORK IN GEORGIA.
>> DO YOU VOTE IN GEORGIA?
STICK I DON'T.
THERE ARE 30 PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE
TO VOTE IN GEORGIA.
DON'T INTERRUPT ME.
THE PEOPLE THAT WORK ON MY
CRUISE, THE PEOPLE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY EMPLOYED
DO.
VOTING ON WHAT WAS INSIDE THE
BILL.
>> Kennedy: SHE HAS CREATED A
WHOLE COTTAGE INDUSTRY FOR
HERSELF.
SHE IS THE ANNOYING POLICE.
JESSE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO MAKE SOME
DISCLOSURE.
I HAVE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
WITH THE STORY.
ALYSSA MILANO WAS MY CRUSH WHEN
I WAS GROWING UP AND I LOVED HER
ON "FULL HOUSE."
I THOUGHT SAMANTHA WAS FANTASTIC
FOR HER.
I ALSO HAD A CRUSH ON LORI
LOUGHLIN.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO COMMENT ON
PEOPLE ALL HAD A CRUSH ON WHEN I
WAS A SIX OR SEVEN OR 8-YEAR-OLD
BOY BUT I'M GOING TO DO IT
ANYWAY BECAUSE THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
I AM NOT BIASED WHEN I SAY THIS.
I THINK IT'S FINE WHAT SHE'S
DOING.
I THINK IT'S OKAY TO GO IN AND
CONFRONT POLITICIANS WHERE THEY
WORK.
THAT'S PART OF THE DEMOCRACY.
I WISH MORE PEOPLE DID THAT.
I WISH MORE PEOPLE DID IT ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF COURSE, BUT SHE
HAS EVERY RIGHT TO GO IN THERE
AND RAISE HELL.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS KIND OF RUDE
WHEN SHE SAID DON'T INTERRUPT
ME.
I DON'T THINK SHE NEEDED TO DO
THAT BUT I'M GOING TO GIVE HER A
PASS BECAUSE I LIKE HER.
IF ANYTHING, THIS IS GOING TO
GET HER MORE PRESS FOR HER
SPECIAL, WHATEVER SHE'S FILMING
DOWN THERE.
>> Kennedy: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE DOLLARS AND CENTS.
CELEBRITIES AREN'T THE ONES WHO
DECIDE WERE PRODUCTION AND
WHERE SHOWS ARE FILMED.
STATES LIKE GEORGIA GIVE
COMPANIES LIKE NETFLIX A LOT OF
MONEY AND A LOT OF TAX BREAKS IN
ORDER TO COME AND SHOOT THERE
BECAUSE THEY HELP THE LOCAL
ECONOMIES.
>> Dana: YES, HOWEVER SOME
STATES SAY IT DOESN'T REALLY PAY
OFF.
I THINK THESE LEGISLATURES WOULD
BE BETTER OFF KEEPING THEIR
TAXES LOW, MAKING SURE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT RUNS EFFICIENTLY AND
SPENDING ALL THAT EXTRA MONEY
THAT THEY GIVE DOLLYWOOD ON
ADVERTISING IN NEW ENGLAND,
ESPECIALLY NEWARK, NEW JERSEY,
CONNECTICUT, SAYING WOULDN'T YOU
RATHER KEEP X AMOUNT OF
MONEY IN YOUR POCKETS AND LIVE
YOUR LIFE THE WAY YOU WANT TO
LIVE IT.
THAT'S A BETTER WAY TO SPEND
TAXPAYER MONEY.
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO COME THERE.
YOU HAVE A TAX BASE.
NOT PEOPLE SO FICKLE WHO WANT TO
LEAVE.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE, YOU ARE
VOTING THE WAY YOUR CONSTITUENTS
WANT.
>> Kennedy: HOW ARE THEY GOING
TO VOTE HERE?
DO CELEBRITY INPUT HAVE ANY
INFLUENCE ON THE METRIC AS FAR
AS THIS CONVERSATION?
>> Tom: OBVIOUSLY.
THEY CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF THE
CELEBRITIES.
I DON'T KNOW WIRELESS MILANO.
THERE ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT
EVERYBODY CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF.
I SEE HER EVERY DAY.
I DON'T GET IT.
PETE DAVIDSON.
WHY IS PETE DAVIDSON AND THE
NEWS EVERY SINGLE DAY?
>> Kennedy: KATE BECKINSALE.
THERE'S AN AGE GAP.
SHE'S SUPER PRETTY.
>> Tom: YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
CHILDHOOD CRUSHES.
>> Jesse: IS THAT YOURS?
>> Tom: I GUESS I WAS PARTIAL
TO JAN BRADY.
OKAY.
>> Kennedy: THIS IS GETTING
WEIRD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: IMAGINE JAN BRADY
GROWS UP AND SHE IS A HELL-BENT
SOCIALIST AND SHE STARTS RIPPING
IN THROUGH EVERYONE'S
LEGISLATURE AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
>> Tom: YOU ARE PART OF THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE YOU KEEP CUTTING
HER SLACK BECAUSE YOU HAD A
CRUSH ON HER.
>> Jesse: YOU WANT TO ROAST
THE WOMAN?
YOU DO?
>> Kennedy: JUAN, I WILL LET
YOU BE THE ULTIMATE REFEREE.
BETWEEN JESSE AND --
>> Juan: I'M GLAD WILMA
FLINTSTONE DIDN'T GO INTO THE
GEORGIA LEGISLATURE.
[LAUGHTER]
I WISH WE HAD RUN THE TAPE IN
FULL BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
CAMERAMAN GOES UP TO THE STATE
SIMILAR MINUTES AS THE KOCH
BROTHERS WHO ARE FUNDING THE
ANTIABORTION ISSUE, THEY DON'T
LIVE HERE EITHER.
HE DOESN'T HAVE AN ANSWER.
I THINK THAT WOULD'VE BEEN THE
WHOLE STORY.
HE GETS EMBARRASSED BY THE
REALITY THAT HE HAS A DOUBLE
STANDARD IN TERMS OF WHO COMES,
AS JESSE WAS SAYING, RAISING
PUBLIC CONCERNS ABOUT A VERY
PUBLIC AND CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE,
THE HEARTBEAT ABORTION BILL.
TO ME, THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS
THAT SHE'S A CELEBRITY AND SHE'S
USING HER CELEBRITY TO ADVANCE
HER POLITICAL AGENDA AND THAT'S
A GREAT AMERICAN TRADITION.
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD DO IT.
YOU WANT TO SPEAK OUT, THIS IS
THE ONE COUNTRY YOU CAN --
>> Kennedy: SLOW DOWN.
SHE'S NOT JACKIE ROBINSON.
SHE'S NOT KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR.
>> Dana: WOULD'VE JESSE WENT
TO WASHINGTON TO THE D.C.
CITY COUNCIL AND COMPLAINED.
>> Jesse: THEY WOULDN'T LET ME
IN.
>> Dana: THEY WILL.